oh boy I almost didn't make it here to
era Joe Lewis is in rare form this
morning and he just hit me in the nards
with his tail so I love him but uh he'll
be placed in a closet for weeks in peten
without Mercy hey look uh major
announcement here well major
announcement coming Monday
and we'll be talking about Tucker
Carlson today and I hear a lot of
similarities
so in navigating all of these minefields
look I hear your complaints and I've
heard this a lot from people I had
someone who was actually just a kid who
would do valet at this restaurant
relatively close to my house who came up
and said you know he signed up for mug
Club a while ago last year you know
money is tight
I understand it look I hear that I hear
where you're coming from we tried to
give you guys anyone who had signed up
for mug club right mugclub forever.com a
promo code initially through email some
of you missed it Alex Jones called me
yesterday come up to me at uh at Bucky's
telling me you know he wants to sign up
again but you know he already signed up
and didn't get a mug so look starting on
Monday with as broad a stroke as I can
possibly make here wanting to do right
by you understanding that the economy is
tough It's Growing but slowly they say
on CNN uh and through no fault of your
own sometimes it's tough to subscribe to
multiple different platforms especially
when you already have starting Monday
we are going to set up an email address
where you can provide proof through a
screenshot of a subscription purchase
membership to any
right leaning streaming service any
major right Street conservative
right-leading streaming service
and we'll give you three months free of
mug Club so send in proof of purchase
your subscription from any time in the
last I think it's last year last six
months that you have signed up
particularly if it was mug Club
three months free we're going to have
someone manually actually going through
and ensuring that you get to try this
for free and by the way for three months
you get to try it if you don't like it
you can bounce hopefully you see what it
is that you're missing uh we want to
give you the best value for your money
and look sometimes in this world there's
things out of your control and I get it
the economy is tough
three months free if you are a member
anywhere else Monday look for the email
on with the show
thank you
[Music]
you're a fast Colton it's not healthy
the hell would you know about health
Miss forklift with teeth
get the stupid show called they don't
care about you Jimmy what was that
even know you that's your life straight
from the fear of hell and you know it
take a look right there boom don't want
to hear any more of your glass
and that was not a real sound guy it's
just a character he plays I've had it
with your lies Josephine in back of me
Satan okay
woman I'm quoting scripture for my Lord
and Savior Jesus Christ maybe if you put
down your soap bags every once in a
while for a hot minute you know better
join my club today for 89 annually to
support content like this and get access
to the entire network live with
crowder.com
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
chair if he wants it we need to take a
poll do people want the Sip to continue
is it like one of those almost like the
HBO white noise that doesn't sound like
white noise
or is it just annoying
that's just how I feel by the way this
is a grip trainer I don't know why I
have that on my desk hey a lot to get to
today uh we talked about Tucker Carlson
was it was it Tuesday Gerald uh I think
we did it live on was it I thought it
was Monday Monday that's right CNN
Monday and then talked about the Curious
coincidences of you know you have Tucker
Carlson you have James O'Keefe if you
have obviously Dan bongino was a little
bit of a different situation but this
has been going on across the board and
we said that these seemed like Curious
coincidences
and it would appear that there's a
culture of shaking people down right now
specifically to Cull voices before the
election
and there's new evidence that's emerged
today with Tucker Carlson that really
seems like that's the case we've seen
his first statement but we've also seen
some statements from attorneys and
people who seem to be the Shaker downers
so we'll talk about that we're going to
be talking about everyone's really
excited because I know a lot of you said
hey you know I really like Western's
good old American westerns but they need
more sodomy so you have that now
um Xi Jinping called zelinski this is a
big deal I know a lot of you are saying
why do I care well it affects you and
more importantly I really wanted to get
into the ESG you guys have heard of the
ESG scores in bankings but there have
been some recent interviews where this
is going to be taking place at Hyper
Speed with BlackRock Vanguard and it
will affect you directly in your
day-to-day lives not only what you can
do with your Banks what kind of loans
you can get if you run a business how
you have to run this business this is
one of those weeks where everything
seems to be kind of fallen from the same
tree that's been shaken and it all
affects you so let me ask you a question
today before we move on who do you think
is really behind the fire hearing or
departure or Mutual amicable split
with Tucker Carlson uh we'll kind of
give you some of our some of our
perspective I saw you writing notes
already Jill did I mess something up no
I mean I I have a I have an answer for
you very quickly Chad would like the Sip
hold on
my heart's not I just
yeah
that is all you get you earn it
burn this
[Laughter]
oh and uh one of my all-time favorite
people nicest man alive unfortunately
Joe Morgan how are you I am doing well
why is that unfortunate it's unfortunate
because sometimes I need you to be you
know you need to be my Bulldog yeah
sometimes I don't want to get tuckered
well you know put me back in the chair
last Thursday I was that's true I was a
little pissy you were pissy you could do
you do get but you get more
every once in a while people push me
just a little too far I'm doing really
yes that's true and then it's falling
down yes kind of cold 39 Cent so much
I'm doing well yeah you know it's the
end of the week so tired but I'm really
glad to have uh in search here we said
mystery third year but it's not really a
mystery if you follow his social media
he's going to be
that's his theme song Comedy Zone Port
Charlotte Florida May 5th and 6th you
can go and check out all of his other
dates oh Stress Factory that's a fun one
in uh in New Brunswick New Jersey May
11th and 13th briancallen.com Mr calall
how are you I'm good I'm good and I
appreciate that uh that music guy that
that's the uh music that I ride a horse
to us you know yes so uh and and side
table side saddle he's never ridden a
horse yeah that's uh equestrian or
western style that's ridiculous ask me
if I ride horses dressage I don't like
where this is going it's okay just ask
me the question that's how I answered
you promise I know people can ask me on
the street Yeah well yeah and let me
just let me just let me answer it for
you so I don't have to Def yeah the
street is Folsom uh she has to go ahead
do you ride horses
well the night is still young stop it
Big and Rich why is Steven wearing a
horse tail
no no I had it docked is that what
that's why Peter was out there
protesting
crapping in the shed and it got caught
I know you can't haven't you seen my
Japanese so okay I've seen it I lived it
and you guys can come we're going to get
into all of the story it's a month it's
a Monday through Friday show 10 a.m
Eastern okay 10 a.m Eastern just watch
on Rumble you have the audio podcast
tomorrow exclusively on audio if you are
not a member of the Lost Tapes it's
another 45 minutes of old sketches and
of course we have the Friday show here
on Mud Club exclusively but uh I was
just about to say something I completely
forgot what I was about to say you said
have you seen the Japanese something oh
toilet so you know this when they built
out the office see that they built out
this office right and I now actually
have an office and I actually have a
bathroom that's because I live here from
like 4 a.m right so we need to shower
here sometimes especially after and uh
very nice man Joe who doesn't but
sometimes he gets overzealous with the
technology yeah well I have a safe here
for a gun that I I cannot open the
batteries are dead so he builds puts in
I'm just like yeah just a toilet and
he's like what kind of toilet do you
want like just you know one that I can
defile yes and uh he got this like thing
with it's like it has like the the
heated seats it does yeah the automatic
flush sprayer and Mr Hollow I come off
the chest he goes he goes yeah I tried
to take a dump in your office it turns
out I need a pilot's license to operate
that
it's fair first off you shouldn't be
using my office there are plenty of
bathrooms I'm going to come in your
office and just drop a deuce but you
know what when I look at you about Chuck
Yeager of taking a I guess you're
just like okay but at least my whistles
clean hi everybody you can eat off my
whistle yeah after you ride a horse so
here's a clip before we get to the
Tucker issue we're going to go through
the Tucker situation just kind of Point
by Point it'll be a little bit raw today
uh because we couldn't segment it into
90 Clips but before that
uh because we always want to clear the
palette and this really clears the
palette it's like sorbet if sorbet was a
really unattractive self-important fat
chick uh she wants to take up space No
Lie this summer my body is everything to
me she has constantly looked the world's
greatest in the eye and said I disagree
you're wrong and I'm going to show up
every day and show you why I deserve the
best this summer I want you to embrace
your body and I want you to come over to
tell the world you're wrong and I'm
going to show up and take up the space
my body deserves a lot of space well
she's got a pretty face remember the man
remember they complained about man
spreading yes what do you do with that
yeah what do you do with that what do
you do with that orbit on us so and by
the way here's the thing no one would
have a problem no one would have a
problem if you weren't demanding that
everyone declare you beautiful my body
disagrees with what your BMI your LDL
your body probably just it's probably
constantly at war with itself your heart
one day is going to go
and check out yeah diabetes and here's
something else too the big issue here is
I deserve the best and I'm not just
talking about this woman
this is by the way you get a lot of guys
this way a lot of you why deserve the
best this is a question of the day this
is actually an existential issue you
just say that
why do you deserve the best why does
everyone think they deserve the best do
you know that some of us deserve hell
well you know what's funny you guys
talking about horses again
um but my thing is that every time you
see a woman like that she conforms to a
certain Beauty whatever dish
God made a mold for all of us okay and
her mold he used more batter for that
mold and that's all there is to it but
bundt cake but but like her face is very
pretty and it conforms to a sort of the
standard classic Beauty but full mouth
and they always kind of fit into this
thing but the other part is like they're
like it's okay for slightly chubby so
long as you have Perfect Skin yes
exactly like you're you're a little I
mean Fitness athletes some crossfitting
female with folliculitis she's like what
I do
you didn't use Dove no you didn't use
Dove it's just a tour or that Japanese
toilet yes exactly Gerald anything no
well just uh the hair is what bothered
me
what what let me see it again
it was it was let me see it let's play
this again
let me see tomboy oh yeah that's not
flattering it's not a pretty face Brian
no I think her face is pretty my body my
body was meant to be Shemp if that broad
came as a guy I believe it you know what
I mean to be fair I looked at her face
then I saw mine on the monitor here and
that's just like I'll take her face all
day long well I mean I'll keep my
shredded my Ridiculousness look we've
never once in the show just people never
once ever ever made fun of someone just
for being fat who doesn't go out there
and demand or declare or act as an
ambassador of Health the problem is I
just heard someone on CNN today maybe we
can even pull this clip it probably was
what are we 9 24 so it probably was
taking place uh I'm trying to think
central probably about 7 40 Central if
we can pull it where guy I think it was
rain Wilson talking about we have a
mental health crisis in this country and
we have a climate change crisis we have
a fascism crisis people talk about a
mental health crisis people talk about a
physical health crisis but then they
advocate for the exact same issues that
create these crises you cannot start art
you cannot start from a position of
empathy based on a lie to say that that
is healthy and to say that everyone else
should accept it and we should add if
you Advocate that to your children
you're a bad parent and you're lying to
them that's why it matters also I think
it's kind of gross but that's just me
let's move on
Tucker make thongs in that size okay can
we just say that was that not make
thongs well I don't think they do I
think everything becomes a song there
are men that like that yes there are
yeah that there is a fetish yeah but
it's just called black guys Brian
[Laughter]
we knew someone who remembered she was
uh she was a little bit bigger and she
would always get hit on by black guys
yeah and she was like why didn't she
would ask why do oh like I just she she
by the way she would date black guys she
said why do I only have black guys hit
on me and you're like I don't know
that's weird all right yeah
it's cultural yes yeah it's a mystery
that's a disgusting habit So speaking of
mystery and uh hit the like button if
you're watching on YouTube but head on
over to rumble as a matter of fact if
you are watching on YouTube and at any
point today which I guarantee you will
see or hear this
just head on over to rumble because
we're not going to self-censor for
YouTube and we'll probably be suspended
anyway so yesterday Tucker Carlson
released his first statement now there's
some insight here that I think uh
unfortunately it's hard to disseminate
sometimes uh as from from our standpoint
and it's hard for you to sort of
differentiate right when you're reading
stories out there and get the truth was
he fired did he quit what's happening
behind the scenes
um in watching his statement in full
disclosure I've spent some time with
Tucker not a lot of time with Tucker
they've always been pretty Pleasant
interactions cordial right we're not
it's not like we were ever friends or
anything but we were both at Fox News at
the same time before we had a show we
were contributors so I want you to know
that in case you think that I'm biased
probably because I think he's generally
a nice guy from what I've encountered
and what I've heard okay so just to be
clear I think we've gotten that either
it's covered there you go disclaimer
um in watching his statement
I really understand what it is that he's
trying to say he's limited from things
that he can say he has a lawsuit right
so when that happens your lawyers say
you cannot say anything so Tucker is
right now in a position here's we don't
know everything what we do know is he
would not be able to clear his name if
that were the case
if if if everything that you read out
there is a light there's nothing he can
say about it until it goes through the
proper legal channels and depending on
how he left Fox News whether they fired
him or he left he can't actually clarify
that to you either because of the terms
of employment now this is standard
practice across the board sometimes it's
worse than others so in watching Tucker
Carlson's uh statement let's just watch
it pause and play it and kind of read
between the lines I think there's a lot
here
good evening it's Tucker Carlson one of
the first things you realize when you
step outside the noise for a few days is
how many genuinely nice people there are
in this country kind and decent people
people who really care about what's true
and a bunch of hilarious people also a
lot of those it's got to be the majority
of the population so pause really
quickly here's what he's saying there
he's had to work amongst Elites for a
very long time in this industry what
he's trying to say is they are
disconnected from you this is why you've
heard us say here you watching listening
you are what matters a lot of sponsors
out there a lot of networks out there
right you are a means to an end dollars
and there are a lot of hosts and by the
way a lot of producers a lot of people
who work at these companies who don't
feel that way you are what matter what
he is saying there is that he cares and
is grateful for you and then it's kind
of a passive way saying not these
let's keep playing
so that's heartening the other thing you
notice when you take a little time off
is how unbelievably stupid most of the
debates you see on television are
they're completely irrelevant they mean
nothing in five years we won't even
remember that we had them
trust me as someone who's participated
pause
what do you think that means
do you think that suggests that Tucker
liked doing right sort of Click bait
debates no
that means that sometimes when you work
for a big company their orders that come
from the top down and by the way ratings
ratings this is the same place just to
be clear this is the same place Fox News
when I was there that said absolutely
not change my mind would never work
um yeah and it was before Fox Nation
where I said they had Studio B I said
let's just do it online and see what
happens like no no it's got to be in a
quadrant view it's got to be Snappy you
each have to have just a minute and get
your points in I said okay well look
this is what I would like to do no way
it would never be permissible not just
at Fox News but at other news outlets as
well and by the way a lot of online
Outlets as well that is him saying I
have done this and it's silly it's
useless it's almost a professional
wrestler breaking k-fape Cafe
is that is that two is that to satisfy
your demographic though because there
are certain demographic that watches Fox
so if you grade against what they want
to see they have time constraints with
sponsors right they have time
constraints and so they don't want to
have a conversation they want to have a
beginning middle and end before or every
single spot that breaks the commercial
and that doesn't lend itself to
long-form conversations no there's a
huge difference between having
conversations like Tucker said with
average everyday Americans both right
and left and people who are paid to go
on score points and then raise money for
their non-profit it's a show yes no and
his most effective part of his show is
his monologue that was it after the
monologue I really didn't want to listen
to anything else because I'm like I want
to hear a long form maybe five ten
minutes long right of a comment or
something that he's talking about
because the rest of it I know is going
to be that format and by the way his
monologues really were different from a
lot of it look whether you like them or
not he was taking risks with those and
that was where he had 15 minutes
unfettered I bet you that's what he
really loved to do because if you look
at his his uh response here he never
even alludes to being unsatisfied with
that he's letting you know the things
this is just again my speculation but
having been through this industry and
been through similar circumstances he's
letting you know the things that might
have been outside of his control that he
wasn't huge fan of in which he had to
take part and in not mentioning the
things that he was dissatisfied with you
can kind of glean oh I think this is
what he's about and what he liked let's
continue yeah this same time and this is
the amazing thing the undeniably big
topics the ones that will Define our
future get virtually no discussion at
all war civil liberties emerging science
demographic change corporate power
natural resources
come on you know what that science he's
talking about covet of course everyone
in the media we know we were suspended
right if we were suspended because we're
independent at Fox News there was
pressure coming from the government to
make sure that he did not discuss new
Sciences civil liberties that also would
tie back to covet when he talks about
issues of our time January 6th we all
know the kind of flack that he got and
he thought it was important to correct
that record I understand it I know the
kind of heat that they probably were
bringing down on him and God bless him
for doing it anyway I can only tell you
how many times when I was there for four
and a half years this is a contributor
being called into the second floor like
you can't talk about that why because
it's just it's just too much it's truth
it's just too much too much truth people
can't handle that so I think this is
very Illuminating and you guys can can
jump in where you where you want but I
think uh there are a couple more points
here that if you read between the lines
are pretty telling last time you heard a
legitimate debate about any of those
issues it's been a long time debates
like that are not permitted in American
Media both political parties and their
donors have reached consensus on what
benefits them and they actively collude
to shut down any conversation about it
suddenly the United States looks very
much like a one-party State pause that's
a depressing it's very clear both sides
collude
it's very similar to what you've heard
me talk look if there's let's say
there's only two companies in town and
one is supposed to be black hat one's
supposed to be white hat and they both
have a conversation and say look these
are the issues that we have with Tucker
so if you want them we're going to do
this with them it's illegal in sports by
the way to let another team know or at
least in certain Sports what you're
offering them what the contract is like
what the terms are on the way out this
happens in our industry all the time
Tucker just told you he just reiterated
something that we talked about in
December yeah there are people who are
more powerful than you and they're very
concerned if they think that Tucker is
more powerful than Fox News in and of
itself and that's something that they
have to eliminate as a threat he did not
just say CNN CNN's not a threat read
between the lines CNN is not a threat
right
MSNBC is not a threat he cannot say Fox
News and I'm not saying this is right or
wrong I'm telling you what it seems he's
trying to say that I know he's precluded
from saying he made sure to say both
sides powerful corporate entities
collude to eliminate these conversations
that is very very specific and that's
not by accident let's keep going
civilization but it's not permanent our
current orthodoxies won't last they're
brain dead nobody actually believes them
hardly anyone's life is improved by them
this moment is too inherently ridiculous
to continue and so it won't
the people in charge know this that's
why they're hysterical and aggressive
they're afraid they've given up
persuasion they're resorting to force
but it won't work when honest people say
what's true calmly and without
embarrassment they become powerful pause
without embarrassment
why would he say that he doesn't need to
say that that'll bring us to the
Shakedown elements later this is
something that's very common right
there's going to be Discovery with this
lawsuit every single text he's ever sent
every single message that he's ever sent
with no context with no context see when
you read a text you have no you can't
tell if it's a joke it sounds serious
and they'll read into that and they'll
read it that way and this is what
happens a lot with people in positions
of of a high profile like Tucker Carlson
they're going hey I bet you don't want
everyone to read every single joke or
text you've ever said even though I've
never met you and you've never done
anything wrong this is something that's
going to go into public Discovery that's
he did not need to say that when honest
people speak the truth calmly and
without embarrassment one of these
things is not like the other he is
letting you know and he could he could
tell me that everything I'm saying is
wrong and I'm doing a gross disservice
in which case I apologize I'm trying
yeah to to help out what I think is
being said here and we'll get into the
lawsuit without embarrassment that's key
and hopefully Tucker Carlson understands
and you guys can comment below that he
barring some kind of a crime if there
are some jokes out there this is
probably what's going to come down the
pike nothing to be embarrassed about
let's start with the Pearl clutching
acting like we all in our own quiet time
with friends don't say things that out
of context could be used against you
every single one of you right now right
now would you want the entire world the
entire world to see everything you've
sent in the last five years to anybody
you've ever talked to
that's what he's probably facing with
these bogus lawsuits and they're bogus
my entire life on this show has lived
out of context with a soundboard that's
true
that's okay in point but no I want to go
back to a word that he said and and I
was going to make this point a second
ago but he actually highlighted it when
he said these orthodoxies can't last so
they won't as somebody who in Tucker's
case has worked at MSNBC at CNN and now
at Fox News I think he's referring to
them
he's referring to the Legacy yes these
Legacy Media Outlets can't last look at
the the shake-up that you're seeing at
CNN the shake up to some degree at MSNBC
now the shake-up at Fox this is this is
the death throws of an industry right
now is what you're saying and he's
referring to it and saying they're on
the way out and he's one of the only
people who was not on the way out yeah
and that should tell you something look
you don't get rid of your star player
when they are at their Peak there's
something going on here and and you know
I understand Tucker probably looking out
for the best interests uh of of his
family of covering himself legally as
their ongoing suits has to be very very
careful but that's a good point Joe
let's keep watching
in time the Liars who've been trying to
silence them shrink and they become
weaker that's the iron law of the
universe true things prevail
where can you still find Americans
saying true things there aren't many
places left but there are some and
that's enough
as long as you can hear the words there
is hope
see you soon there you go there are some
and that's enough he's alluding to now I
really really hope that Tucker has a
very good lawyer and is very careful
because sometimes you see people who go
from Legacy Media online and they assume
that online means free the wild west it
does not and by the way that's on
absolutely both sides so there are some
places where you can speak freely Rumble
is one of them it's not the only one but
it certainly is one of them and the one
making the most amount of progress so it
seems to me like Tucker is saying I need
to get to a point where I am free to
speak what I actually believe and just
to be clear here I wanna in defense of
him because you'll see this a lot and I
have had the luxury of not having anyone
dictate what I say that is a luxury for
which I am supremely grateful I have
tried yeah yeah you know what I will say
the things that I'm most grateful for in
my life is that I get to come to work
with you Johnny but my best friends for
for the better part of two well John
Johnny Boy three three decades but two
decades uh and that win lose or dry get
to say what it is that I mean but I also
see people maybe saying well then why
did Tucker do this if he didn't believe
this which we don't know what's been
said again there's a lot of speculation
it does not mean that someone is
controlled opposition if they speak the
truth but they are for they're not
allowed they're barred from speaking the
whole truth they want to communicate I'm
willing to bet that that is a situation
with Tucker I do not believe that Tucker
Carlson has ever said anything that he
does not believe I don't think that he
would do that but I do believe that
there were instances where he was not
allowed to communicate the entirety of
the truth that he wanted to convey
that's very different that's what
happens a lot is well look look we're
not going to tell you what to say but if
you say this you know you might just uh
it's worse when you're a contributor
which she was for a long time if you say
it this way then you know we might just
you know we might just not to get your
regular uh your regular Wednesday spot
yeah that's what happens it's the things
that you're not permitted to say but
information is becoming decoratized the
the marketplace wants you to not be
beholden to a corporation what would
have made that video even more powerful
if that a paper Mission and if Don Lemon
had walked by in just an apron yes
nothing button just said amen right you
know you know what I mean yeah or tell
them honey that would have been cool too
sassy sassy
you're gonna say what would actually
make that video uh just Don Lemon Water
oh okay I was gonna say he's describing
a fantasy or in the in the g string that
that woman was wearing in it doesn't
matter the point is to have Don Lemon
and one other person look what the point
is that that I I didn't really read into
it that way but I do think that the
marketplace is creating space yeah for
objective news and information yeah and
he's gonna he's gonna do it he should
team up with Don Lemon and they should
have a point Counterpoint it'd be kind
of interesting I bet you Don Lemon is a
lot more conservative than you think uh
no no no no it used to be they used to
ask me I couldn't exactly he had to he
had to tow that line too you're gonna
start seeing a lot of people like that
who are like I'm actually a lot more in
the middle yeah no I think you're just
going to be seeing him starting in the
Off-Broadway version of Birdcage
yes well look we do have some breaking
news we mentioned him a minute ago and
we talked about large white women and
people
um and I said yeah I've watched Jerry
Springer well he's dead oh no Jerry
Springer
79 years he was also was he mayor of
Cincinnati yes yeah I mentioned him and
30 seconds later he's dead I'm sorry I
mean I'm not a Jerry Springer fan but uh
I mean I mean I didn't watch the show is
what I mean I don't really know a whole
lot about him personally but that said
79 is is Young well what what 79's
pretty I mean well you're six foot five
so you'd be lucky to make it that far
Great Danes don't live very long though
also the lady in that first clip they
don't see a lot of 80 year old thems no
she she
was cozy like that'd be fun to sleep
next to her on okay but we can move on
from sorry we can move on from the
disgusting I'm just saying we can move
on from the middle stage from the middle
Act of Slither which is what we just
witnessed something's wrong with me
okay I gotta I gotta leave uh after the
show yes after the show
but that's it with Tucker you know what
hey look we always offer uh extend a
hand if Tucker wants to tell a story
whatever it is that he can tell and of
course he doesn't owe anyone anything
everyone is we always try and balance
people are reaching out for a scoop
right so look if you need someone to be
a helping hand uh or help navigate
what's going on we're here and if not I
understand Tucker's got to do what he's
got to do and I'd love to see you
comment below if you what do you think
before we get into some new information
this might end up being the whole show
we have so much I know discuss this is a
lot does he get bigger from this
well I mean you know I mean you tend to
stress eat no no well that's not what I
mean why does everything you've got food
on the brain I do no you made it you
made a really good point about this when
when you transitioned like uh um oh geez
I'm forgetting his name but anyway the
former talks uh Fox guy who was really
really big went there right before Bill
O'Reilly biller I think I can't believe
maybe we'll do it live it yeah
exactly
guy like that goes on to stream it's not
like filling a spot on right now the big
difference is Bill O'Reilly did it right
when he got in trouble for all the right
you know that's true yes
but Bill O'Reilly did just think that he
could go online and do a podcast and of
course nobody and and I don't say I
don't Revel on this look when you don't
have other people marketing you when you
don't have other people telling you what
it is that you need to listen to and
having a built-in bass right fox has a
basement and then Tucker did a lot
better than the bass level than the
other host but so did Bill O'Reilly and
then people realize when he has to write
his own content uh it wasn't interesting
enough in a sea of far greater
competition I think Tucker would do a
lot better than Bill O'Reilly yeah I
think he would get neutered if he goes
to the wrong place right I think right
now is pivotal if he goes to the wrong
place if he does not stay he has his own
Studio at his place right he might have
to change a little bit because Fox might
said that they technically own some
imagery or something like that he has
his own place he has the money to float
this for a while like we did for a while
to ensure that he creates the kind of
show that he wants to there are people
like Rumble there are other of people
but Rumble is the most capable right now
that could help him do his own thing
this is pivotal I know he's having
meetings with people Tucker just take
your time and don't do anything that
would lock you down from that would have
anything even remotely close to the
shackles that you've just uh you've just
sort of escaped that's that's what I
would say yeah and he's got to make a
big splash coming out of doing something
different he can't just talk to the
camera and expect every single person to
follow but no exactly you said in this
and there's too much there's too many
options there's too many he's got his
head writer with him yeah well no that's
helpful but it's not box at seven right
right that time's like carries weight
with it like Steven said the basement so
you got older people too if he has his
head writer hey Tucker can I just can I
can I borrow him uh
what yeah
we have we have brilliant research we do
people who help with this a lot uh so we
just had Brian kellen's comedy that is
uh you know what hey that's not nice
guys
warming up it's my lilac nobody
understanding about my lilac sweatshirt
I love you bro that is not Lila what are
you color by the way Gerald's colorblind
he wouldn't know I know oh you are yeah
this this kind of calms the masculine
Edge there you go yeah exactly it was
too much now I'm like oh you're he's
just like me otherwise I'm too dangerous
yeah exactly my jawline right right cuts
too much of an image all right so here's
the other info on Tucker I don't know if
you've been following this Brian yes uh
this is from The New York Times they
suggested that Tucker's firing had to do
with a lawsuit by his booking producer
Abby grossberg okay so let me read you a
quote from the New York Times and then
let me give you some context Miss
grossberg said in the lawsuit naming Mr
Carlson that male producers regularly
use vulgarities to describe women and
frequently made
anti-semitic jokes uh grossberg
addressed the lawsuit and then okay
first off here's the thing you're gonna
see this clip okay and you're going to
read this on New York Times let me be
clear grossberg's lawyer admitted that
grossberg never met Tucker okay what
never met Tucker so think about Johnny
Amber Heard right that guy even lost in
the UK until we found out that she broke
his finger with the bottle and took a
on the bed multiple times and
blamed a human-sized on a
Pomeranian Yorkshire Terrier I don't
care
but my point here is this woman never
met Tucker according to her lawyer what
keep that in mind while you watch this
clip on MSNBC okay there were feelings
at first like yes
his executive producer Justin Wells
who's also fired
really responsible for breaking me she
looks more making my life a living hell
so there is a feeling of justice but
it's only partial okay so you never met
him and he's responsible for breaking
you first off let me let you let me let
you in a little secret if vulgarities
and by the way if Tucker had called like
a black intern the n-word it would say
that just to be clear right he probably
called someone a right Clarence
Thomas made a joke about a pubic hair on
a Diet Coke can and that made me like it
more I want to party with Thomas then
she got mad because they had pictures of
uh Nancy Pelosi in a bikini everywhere
yes oh no oh no but by the way when
someone threw some holy water on her
she's got that she's looks like she
dresses like an Amish woman she looks
like orphan eyes she's a boogie producer
hold on great white shark he's not
writing content and working intimately
with Tucker Carlson and having to work
through how to write in somebody else
she's saying do you want to be on our
show yeah by the way is that what she
does don't do anything intimately with
her with anything you want back so I
know but I find her stranger strangely
hold on guys this is important this is a
Shakedown this is no no it's okay but
this is a Shakedown because and Brian
you've been through this right something
similar right I hope and you tell me I
don't mean to be out of line but that's
something we talked about you came on
our show remember that conversation
Brian
you're gonna come on the show and you're
going to tell me exactly what you told
me off there it's because you're telling
me the truth that's right and that's how
you have to get out uh in front of these
because right now you have The Daily
Show you have Kimmel you have Seth
Meyers they're all talking about and
this is the threat right this is the
threat the public threat of oh I know
something about Tucker you don't know he
may be called a booking producer he
never met a the one who's stuck in
a vase next to holy water and sacraments
so
all of these late night hosts have a
secret dossi or they're alluding to it
full of dirt that they may have procured
from Fox News on Tucker here you go
news Executives reportedly have a
dossier of dirt on him
yeah to keep him from attacking the
network Fox News reportedly has a
dossier of alleged dirt AKA and Oppo
file and Tucker Carlson amid their messy
separation from the recently ousted host
as speculation runs rampant about what
exactly led to Carlson's abrupt exit
meanwhile Fox itself is basically acting
like Carlson Rolling Stone in a number
of other sources say Fox News has been
keeping a file of dirt on Tucker and
they're prepared to release it in the
event he goes after the networks
apparently something they do over there
they collect compromising information
about their employees in case they need
to use it but what can they have on
Tucker Carlson I would embarrass him did
he once try to buy a fuel-efficient car
I mean does he have a collection of
paintings that weren't by Hitler I don't
know now here's the thing right he's
look he's in there okay that's a funny
bit but what they're doing right now and
notice this they say this preemptively
to prevent him from attacking the
network let me ask you this question
anyone out there see Tucker in a tech
network no so what's going to happen is
they've now attacked him and then if
Tucker Carlson defends himself they'll
say he attacked us and try and nail him
for defamation that right there that you
just saw that was the opening Salvo and
in case here's the important part there
could be zero truth to this and when you
search this for years to come this is
what you will find this is what they
want to threaten in case you've
forgotten they did the same thing with
President Trump claiming and then it
disappeared that he had repeatedly said
the n-word on the set of The Apprentice
and the clip was incoming but all the
talk has been about the one tape that we
haven't heard tonight as we come on the
air the explosive allegations Omarosa
she's now claiming she's heard a
recording of the president using the
n-word magician Penn Gillette says he
knows for a fact there are tapes of
President Trump saying racist remarks he
says he knows such recordings exist
because he was in the room when at least
one incident happened
that the podium and guarantee the
American people they'll never hear
Donald Trump utter the n-word on a
recording in any context uh I can't
guarantee uh anything but I can tell you
that the president addressed this
question directly I can tell you that
I've never heard it you can't guarantee
it it was a bad mistake how about we
guarantee you first Trevor Noah isn't
that one by the way if you if that
existed you think you'd know about it
yeah that was a media frenzy forever I'm
doing the same thing right now with
Tucker Carlson could Tucker Carlson
guarantee you that there is nothing in
his private Communications that you
might find offensive at some point in
time I can't guarantee you about that
about the first 15 minutes of this show
I'll try it what astonishes me is the
lateral cooperation yeah did the
coordinated cooperation it's
unbelievable it gets worse wow it gets
worse because you have Fox News Right
hey Fox News oh here's what Fox News
so I I have a well go can I can I
because this Fox News and ABC or sorry
it's Seth Meyers I don't know the
networks they all suck okay
they're getting this from Fox News all
right so now you have the entertainment
industry but you've heard me use the
term the entertainment media big Tech
industrial complex that's by Design
because guess who else is happy about it
senior DOD officials at the Pentagon
this is what they said we're according
to Politico we're a better country
without him bagging on our military
every night in front of hundreds of
thousands of people good riddance but no
look it's a cons I'm sure the Deep state
had nothing to do with any of this at
all
[Music]
what the hell I don't I mean I guess
it's the Deep state but here's the thing
think about the Pentagon right he talked
about federal agents which we now know
right when we now know this we now know
federal agents there might have been of
course even military members January 6th
he shined a light on it they don't like
that Fox News says oh you know what we
understand hey please please please
please please kill us less figuratively
and then they leak info to ABC NBC CBS
Comedy Central they're thinking that the
cumulative effect of all these people
who are nowhere near as popular as
Tucker Carlson if they all gone from at
once that they can cut this off at the
pass and set a narrative and it is ugly
and I hope you're aware of it as it's
happening the Pentagon by the way
they're probably happy that Tucker has
gone not just January 6th but they're
probably happy that he's gone because he
would regularly call out directly which
should be the job of the media by the
way they're woke recruiting practices
pregnant women are going to fight our
Wars it's a mockery of the U.S military
while China's military becomes more
masculine as it's assembled the world's
largest navy
our military needs to become as Joe
Biden says more feminine whatever
feminine means anymore since men and
women no longer exist yeah because
there's nothing more feminine than
Rachel Levine either the point is none
of this makes any sense at this point
you can't follow it you missed that
overlay it's a looting Target all the
time there you go oh I was not gonna be
a picture of the Mitch McConnell
look-alike I have two things one I think
we scooped CNN by about 10 minutes again
fantastic job researchers on the Jerry
Springer thing they finally got to it
right that was something that was on the
air but so my we're too busy taking
calls from Fox News in the pentagon look
I understand if you have a guy who's
going rogue and not doing his job and
your kind of bookmarking things for the
future but that doesn't seem like Fox
News is doing it seems like fox is like
Hey we're gonna fire this guy and we
just want to make up as much stuff as
possible out of context so let's just
gather some dirt quote unquote on this
guy to make sure that he never speaks
out against us again that's what it
sounds like here's why these were in
fact that's not right let's say it's
true if Tucker Carlson didn't show up to
work and they wrote that that's an
infraction right yeah Carlson was coming
and drunk I wouldn't care if they wrote
that down and at some point no never
lied about them they said look this is
what we had right but my point is this
is how you read between the lines right
if he came in and he was drunk okay they
would say that's a problem if he came in
and he didn't do his work okay they'd
say that's a problem if he came in and
he lied deliberately and he didn't run
it by them they knew that it was a false
story but he wanted it that would be an
infraction of course they would say that
they wouldn't say vulgar terms that he
may have used pejoratives right that's
not what's happening no one has a
problem with actual workplace
misdeeds they're not even claiming that
no and look it's not lost on us too that
these late night hosts have no love for
Fox and would love to do everything that
they can to take down both Tucker
Carlson and Fox News at the same time
and so I'm not trying to carry water for
them but the fact that they would have a
dirt file on Tucker Carlson scares me
unless it's just like you said well
these are just in fractions yeah that's
different by the way they would have
said that don't uh because you have
access to my computers and stuff don't
read the file labeled uh Gerald's dirt
that's just I have to I understand yes
you do we have to keep him in line I
deleted it but you see what's going on
right now right I mean this is you know
you'd like to think because you're
obviously more out of the closet more
recently as a conservative I mean you've
always been more conservative right but
you're more aggressive is that a fair
way yes okay if you push me over yes I
don't want to misrepresent you but you
know this happens in Hollywood yeah but
I think a part of you likes to think
that it didn't happen in this side and
um I think maybe you're getting a little
bit of a rude awakening unfortunately
this is very common on this side well
it's it's what I worry about is the
money the big money somehow seems to be
aligning there is lateral cooperation
yeah government and big Tech and
corporate corporations I don't know why
it's going on as opposed to
non-corporate corporations well yes
corporate you're usually so articulate
corporate corporations corporate
corporate corporations with corporate
interests that's what I meant yes Gerald
goldbridge many of them are Incorporated
Incorporated some are Locs are ready but
the point remains
um yeah I don't know I I've but this has
been the thing in Hollywood Forever yeah
on a movie set or a TV set you don't
bring your politics if you're
conservative right to you won't work but
here's the thing in the conservative
sphere you don't bring the wrong
conservative politics that's correct
that's the issue right well you come in
and there are certain things that are
permissible and here's the thing look
Let me Give an example do you know how
much on which I disagree with Alex Jones
for crying out loud yeah the guy's a
blast to have in we can sit here and
talk together I would never no if you
ask me do you agree with him on insert
whatever it is here that no and he's
right about a lot of things Brian and I
disagree on things Gerald and I at no
point are you saying oh you can't you
can't say that because unless of course
you're advocating for a crime which you
do all the time but again don't check
out the dark file you don't Advocate
them just commit them slavery was okay
no you know what the heck that's where I
baby kicking in slavery are the two
things this is out of context yeah all
right no one cares Gerald
I'm not sure what the context would be
but if I said okay but hey
if you're bad in the office Gerald just
grabs you in his arms and squeezes until
you say uncle yes yes if you've been
naughty do you have an idea the Mexican
standoff that would take place if it was
you me Gerald all of you guys by the way
you're not getting out of here unscathed
if anyone saw you in run through uh and
Nick depalo and said hey we're gonna
we're gonna release your uh your jokes
that you wrote that didn't make
texts that take place right now I know
it's mutually assured destruction
well I have nothing to hide it
doesn't mean that you're committing a
crime it doesn't mean that you know no
one's they would already tell you if he
was cheating on his wife if he was out
there banging broads and snorting blow
you would know about it for crying out
loud they said that Donald Trump yelled
the n-word repeatedly on camera and they
never provided evidence right if it
existed you wouldn't know instead we
have to deal with someone who says that
Tucker Carlson said mean things even
though she's never met him and Fox News
understands that Tucker is more powerful
than their Network in a lot of ways
people don't want to follow corporations
people want to support people and you
know what Tucker Carlson love him or
hate him does need your support if you
support the idea of being free and
enough of these shakedowns yeah so just
a quick stat it's not going so well for
that time slot I guess we're finding out
what the basement is because kill Mead
guest hosted for Tucker Carlson and had
a 47 drop in viewership
it's he's getting better yeah okay no I
look I understand it's tough to fill
it's tough to to do that but 1.7 million
instead but I want to go back to a point
if if that existed you would have heard
about it that guy right there knew how
to play it right if there's a tape what
was it he offered a hundred thousand
dollars uh uh man right oh Andrew right
right yeah a hundred thousand dollars to
the United Negro College Fund yeah if
they could and I didn't even that's the
name of the fund dumbass yeah so he uh
because people said that he used the
n-word I believe Andrew Breitbart they
accused him of racism he said anyone who
has any proof or evidence provide the
tape I will I no no it wasn't him it was
Congressman Clyburn and they were
walking up to Congress right remember
they're walking up to the steps and uh
they claimed that people were shouting
the Tea Partiers were screaming the
n-word at them and uh the thing is we
had many this was kind of at the Advent
of iPhones I believe it was 2009 or sort
of when they became there was so much
footage from all these different angles
it's almost like how we were promised
DVDs would be
just a slightly clear cassette tape the
point remains so
they said they yelled the n-word and
were spitting on us yeah and Andrew
Breitbart had so much footage he said a
hundred thousand dollars to the United
Negro College Fund for anyone who
provides proof of that happening because
that was used as a catalyst what they're
doing right now we took her Crossing to
label the entire Tea Party Movement as
racist yep and every one of the media
ran with they were yelling the inward
according to right they just ran with it
yeah you know what I'll say you have to
unfortunately at some point you have to
uh make it so clear that it's undeniable
Anthony Weiner we all know now that it's
true the only reason you know that you
don't remember this they were saying
that Andrew Breitbart hacked had someone
hacked Anthony Weiner and that images
were fabricated and he was planning on
coming out and saying this is all false
and they were talking about Alec Baldwin
said this has a whiff of Breitbart to
try and make it seem illegitimate until
Andrew Breitbart that man the man by the
way who is the reason that I am sitting
here today for God's sakes he was the
first he took a set that I did at the
Improv in 2011 and put it on his website
and said you know what you might want to
try this you might want to try letting
your freak flag fly he spoke with me for
45 minutes he took control of Anthony
Weiner's Podium I believe it was at the
Omni Hotel when he was about to go out
and say Andrew breitbart's a liar I did
nothing wrong until Andrew said I have
the pictures and for the sake of the
family I didn't want to release them
they got leaked eventually but before
that Andrew was playing by rules to try
and do the decent thing and instead
weiner came out and on the Fly had to
apologize and resign people will tell
you they were screaming through the
hallway Anthony Weiner is about to go to
the podium Andrew Breitbart goes instead
and you heard Andrew
in the building like a Specter
that came through and everyone went oh
no we've been messing with this guy for
a long time and he has the receipts and
you hope and you pray it doesn't come to
that but we just talked about I don't
know James O'Keefe yeah who are the
other people who we were discussing
earlier Dan bongino was one of them he
left and then Matt Walsh Matt Walsh got
hacked which is absolutely horrible this
is not happenstance now with Tucker I
just you know I I pray for the guy and
hey maybe there's some damning stuff
that he said I don't think so I don't
buy it you can come back and tell me I'm
wrong what bums me out is that we live
in a time when if you take control of
the narrative first and you have a
catchy narrative you win the day right
at least in the short term you'll win
the battle but I think the war is one
would just stick into the truth yeah but
with a guy like that I mean they used to
say you never pick a fight with a guy
who buys ink by the barrel meaning like
if somebody has a platform like a
newspaper that's where the comment came
from you don't pick a fight with them if
you're not right um he has a platform
still he's still Tucker Carlson he still
has a lot of followers obviously are you
saying they shouldn't pick a fight with
him Fox should not pick a fight with him
yeah I disagree I don't think that I'm
not saying they shouldn't it's morally
reprehensible but they have a leg up why
do you think these guys want to make
sure that YouTube that Facebook are
controlled why do you think Fox spends
so much on Advertising let me tell you
when I was at Fox News I would upload
clips from my own interviews on Fox I
had two segments that I would do every
week and then I would appear
intermittently and I would upload them
to YouTube because you know with
different I think I might have had a
hundred thousand subscribers back then
the fox lawyers were getting removed
from YouTube because they said it was a
fad you didn't want it there then they
said oh we can get a ton of traffic and
then they start spending and not just
Fox NBC they spend so much money on
Advertising they do they dictate the
terms of all of big Tech and Tucker does
not have his own platform set up yet
unless you're right is what I was saying
because here's the thing because if
they're wrong sorry no no you're fine
but if they're wrong Tucker still has
plenty of options to be able to tell his
story so here's what he has in his bag
but he has a limited window he does he
has a limited window to do it but I
guarantee you CNN and MSNBC guys would
have him on in a second if it meant
telling them that Fox News was wrong he
doesn't need to do that he's got other
options I don't know that they would I
think they'll they're covering this
story like crazy I don't know if they
would have Tucker yeah but they want us
they want to slander him they want to
slander I don't know that they would
have him on the bigger fish is Fox I'm
guaranteeing the bigger fish is Fox News
they want to take down Fox News and I'm
not saying they should or should be able
to backlash fire they're playing with
fire they'd get some serious backlash
though if they had Tucker Carr he's
saying hiring Tucker Carl no no no why
don't you come on and tell us about the
lies of Fox News because they're they're
threatening to release dirt on you right
now or they do release dirt and Tucker
has to respond I don't think he should
do that but these guys would be foaming
at the mouth to take down Fox yeah maybe
I don't know you know if he didn't show
like this or show like you know your
friend Joe Rogan that would be a lot
smarter for him to do I wouldn't be
surprised if he does yeah I wouldn't be
surprised if he does Joe Rogan I call
him yeah don't give it to him yeah don't
no don't hand out personal numbers Brian
all right guys
don't give it to MSNBC or CNN don't give
them that do it with somebody else yes I
just want to stick it to the corporate
Corporation yes no I know they deserve
it
they've been far too corporate for far
too long we're corporatists but the
problem is Corporate corporations you
know what's coming to an end what the
their corporate Reign Ah that's right
and I'll tell you something this show
the Corp the corporation meter it
doesn't hit red hot does it guys no it
does not I just had it I just had a
conversation with Rumble yesterday and
uh they're great like they're expand
like I just they're great guys that's
all speaking of which right now and
they're not corporate talking about Fox
News I thought it was a clip from
earlier okay CNN
text messages
crude text messages
sorry Nick de Paul is not here ah
off you dumped up Carlson but you
Channel message on Twitter you know
what's crude is the tanks clinging on
for dear life on your zipper
he gave a harsh critique of the state of
television news calling on-air debates
unbelievably stupid
it's not quite what he said yeah but
he's really calling sweetheart uh what
he's really calling unbelievably stupid
is you yeah is all of you you're
irrelevant yeah yes he's pointing at you
well not to a scale okay next but that
outfit's amazing that outfit so spring
2023 yes yes
bring time for CNN that's it we've got
actually so I I know we've gone kind of
Along on a segment I'm sorry hopefully
you guys did because this that's
important so let's just let's just do
the funny and then we'll push the RC to
next week
it'll live which one the last one the
ESG ESG sorry okay we'll do that one
next all right and by the way lets us be
anti-semitic I'm sorry you Jew writer
who helped me with the ESG thing that
we're moving into next week don't get
all jewy on me it's Jewish my God no you
know what you're correct but you'll
always be dewy to me Sam in a wonderful
way you and your unleavened bread
it's just Focaccia no actually
Sam actually because we've done we've
done the ESG segment and yeah that's all
it is he just gets like a question he
does this all the time but he's like I
can't do lemon bread and I'm like so
he's just like it's just like a Focaccia
or like a brioche or whatever like
that's just typical that's just like one
of the choices what a sacrifice yeah
what is sacrifice I don't have enough
air in my breasts
I love God I'll take no air in my bread
yes and we'll complain about it for 30
years not going to hell yeah
that was your Wonder Bread what's this
Lord what's this Mana Oh you mean it's
every thing that we need to sustain life
is we escape slavery but could it have
some fig Jam
[Laughter]
yeah well gluten-free has made it a lot
easier for the Jews so let's move on too
think about it he's having this fast for
for past is it still Passover in the
past no but why is he fasting he's not
fasting is he I don't know Israel turned
75 yesterday the point yeah yeah that's
why he's fasting the point is the point
is he could be in the middle of the most
religious fast that exists and still eat
at California Pizza Kitchen with no
problems there you go it's so we have
life that it's so much easier but then
the problem that you didn't have to deal
with is back in the day people shaking
you down on a national platform for
potentially using something offensive
that I guarantee you your grandfather
said every single time you went for a
visit okay let's move on now to talk
about uh Pedro Pascal on this gay
western we have a seven plus what you're
gonna do but um it's there's gonna be a
new gay western uh which is a big thing
in case you wondered whether they have
to inject it into everything should I
tell people that the rumble button
doesn't matter yeah just do it smash the
rumble button do it because it went late
today oh what guess who's gonna drop his
first gun video tomorrow oh Mr guns in
gear oh there you go that'll be here in
Montclair he's gonna drop his first so
he comes in gear that sounds like a game
video that's his kind of normal stuff
and he goes hey Gerald I went a little
longer I'm like oh how what do you mean
I'm thinking like 30 minutes and he's
like I went an hour and a half great
that's two pieces of content so he's
cutting it up a little bit so he's gonna
release it tomorrow around noon and some
will be on YouTube and then the full
version of Mud Club because he's been
throttled by the way he's been throttled
horribly Shadow band on YouTube uh even
more than other gun channels I think
because he's so likable and effective
yeah he's gonna do a video that he's
been wanting to do for a very long time
but there's no way and it's absolutely
stunning that it wouldn't be allowed go
go watch it and you'll see why it
wouldn't be allowed but you will have no
idea is he gonna come out of like a
cocoon like I am bored I don't think
he's dead
I know you're confused
I am bored
all right so that brings us gay western
to this week's entertainment minute that
second
[Music]
yeah Callan said something and we
couldn't hear him
all right I want to do the show all the
time I know right it's been chaos the
last two days gay William yesterday you
weren't there gay William and Nick
depalo was magic oh my God I heard
laughing was magic I was hiding the last
time did he have a bag on his head no he
had a now he has a luchadorian mask
daddy says if he looks in the camera
goes I look Mexican
that's an amazing William impersonation
I look Max all right so I know this is a
little bit crazy but we all hear our
heart goes out to Tucker Carlson and I
don't even know the guy but I I you know
you just always hate to see people dead
and the good news is that power Dynamic
is Shifting okay moving on from it so
Tuesday the first trailer for the film
that you were really is is uh with Pedro
Pascal who by the way I like
unfortunately and Ethan Hawke the black
phone was a good film but the point is
two things can be true or three things
can be true good actor good film really
bad looking trailer so it's for a new
queer Western which I guess we can say
now because it's 2023 and it's called
The Strange way of life here is the
trailer and I know what you're thinking
it's not a parody
[Music]
she was a father
a woman was found killed in town
[Music]
I don't know the plot
that's real
they're even shooting gay
[Music]
what do you think doesn't make sense
either
me you never loved anyone in your life
yes
so I shot you the working title was
Dusty butthole wrench
a Lancer look out the window
s
please someone cover his face in a
pillow
that was the worst that's so with dicks
and dust yeah uh that's uh yeah that's
that's what I look for in a western well
that's what you always want in a western
like you know you think of the Searchers
or Unforgiven more gay sex you're like
that's that's what it was missing I
couldn't put my finger in don't shoot
him kiss him and by the way it was
originally just so you know too A lot of
people don't know this because
everything is metaverse now you know
with Marvel it was originally slated to
actually be included in the Alec Baldwin
Western metaverse and it was tenderly
titled rusty trombone so that's what
they were going to release and then they
decided you know what oh
sorry
I said England in Santa Claus
oh you Tapper
I was doing the theme music dude someone
five bucks to whoever gets me that clip
of Santa Claus is coming to town with
Mickey Rooney and his little penguin
topper that's exactly what you sounded
like and they kidnapped the bastard
Santa Claus you know two things can be
true at the same does no one remember
this no I don't do you remember it yeah
okay all right fine thanks leave me
hanging on this limb of a wasted child
if we remember it was still funny some
things could be funny even though you
don't get the context that's all I'm
trying to say all right that looks like
a heck of a movie that was the worst
trailer I've ever seen in my life well
he's wearing that fantastic what is that
color is that a fuchsia
six shooters and by the way I read the
synopsis he plays I think Pedro Pascal
plays uh the sheriff and Ethan Hawke
plays a bad guy I thought you said
bottom well he does well I don't know
the movie could be called who's who's on
top yes because they're both very
masculine right so they kind of hit
dicks you know
what happened too much no they hit him
with the you know they hit him with the
uh it's a pistol whip that's what I
meant I thought it was so pistol Whip's
a good name I thought the sheriff
dueling pistols dueling pistols is
fantastic low noon no dos pistolas
I thought I was straight yes
um
there are a lot of different unfraid
titles Unforgiven because it's an
Abomination could be well that's awesome
it's just too long what are you a
Christian yeah Tom Stone because of AIDS
yes
dude it didn't hit the West 80s I'll be
your monkey pox so I will say this if
you're wearing a cowboy hat yeah
um and you're not from Texas and you're
not a real cowboy you're gay
directions
[Laughter]
Spanish for director yes because the
film will make no dinero so the director
Pedro al-modor Amador he's a great
director actually I don't care I've seen
all his movies he pushed back on the
comparisons to Brokeback Mountain saying
it meaning Brokeback Mountain is
animalistic and for me it was impossible
to have that in the movie because it was
a Hollywood movie you could not have
these two guys effing all the time
because that'd be a porn does that be a
western porn yeah exactly right like I
mean that seems self-explanatory right I
don't know about the parental advisory
but you just can't have two Cowboys
having sex not close up on sodomy then
right you would think so well also I
just don't necessarily think that most
people would want it but I don't know
I'm not a focus group can we get Frank
lundson here with his shitty sneakers
yeah
all right how many hands want to see gay
cowboy sex okay okay no hands No Hands
went up no not at all my hand went
halfway up because I'm repressed yes
all right so speaking of all of the
homosexual intercourse in the cowboy
films pilot before I do this did you
want this did you comment below and you
can hit the like button you can share if
you're on Rumble all this stuff whatever
you know the thing to help with the
algorithm did you want this
are you sure about that gay sex are you
sure about that gay sex so since this
film is all about uh sodomy it's time
for this week seven plus one
[Music]
in the chamber
oh my gosh we have so much stuff that we
didn't get to today we did hopefully you
guys understand we had to go through the
Tuckers we have a special guest still
coming later so I'm excited about that
so are we do you told me not to anyways
we have to do this seven plus one this
is this week seven plus one uh things
Progressive say before and possibly
during sex
number seven Brian Callan let's kick
this off be gentle I haven't decided if
this is rape yet oh yeah that's a little
more volume on the seven plus one there
seven plus one things Progressive say
before during potentially after sex uh
number six get ready to do some
reparations because I'm about to check
your privilege
seven plus one thinks progressives say
during sex number five okay the safe
word has to be something we'd never use
in normal life let's go with quarterly
earnings or fouchy yeah
seven plus one thanks for say joining
sex Gerald number four my apologies well
that just seems something you say in
general
seven plus one things that progressives
say during sex uh number three Brian
don't worry it happens to a lot of this
sorry oh I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm not up
don't worry gender terminology liberals
go yell into your cowboy hat
don't worry it happens to lots of these
uh number two
number two say my name brand of FDA
approved medical dilator that's just
something that's it's really more of a
precautionary step wow yeah I use
poppers all right sorry and the seven
plus what the number one thing that's
progressives say during uh before
potentially after sex number one Brian
Cowan is that a prosthetic
non-functioning surgically attached
phallus in your pocket are you just
happy to see me yeah see I just see I
wrote that one and I wanted to see how
you thank you for that tongue twister
it's very tough on the fly yeah I knew
that was one that probably I should have
done nothing roll off the top but I
wanted to see you yeah you want to see
me screw it up no no I wanted to see how
her you know and I I um you know yeah
yeah I always say do you mind keeping
your mask on yes yes exactly yeah and
then I add and then I put it use a
pillow the thing about your mask is it's
my pillow
I haven't been vaccinated yes that's
what I always say right before into your
hat and it says vaccinated vaccinated
and the plus one thing that uh
Progressive say during sex uh nothing
they just speak the language of sweet
tears and regret that has been this week
seven plus one
foreign
in the chamber oh I completely forgot
about this we're going to be taking your
chat it's chat Thursday uh we had so
much to get to on China zelinski but hey
you know what look do me a favor if you
are okay sometimes when we we dive into
one topic more when it's very topical
and we have a lot to say uh comment
comment below let us know because we
always try and hit what is the news of
the day but sometimes you know we want
to make sure that we do a little bit
more of the ins and outs but I have not
forgotten by the way about the Dalai
Lama and that whole tongue thing it's
been on my mind um all week another
thing that I noticed though most
importantly with the Dalai Lama is that
he didn't even shave right look at this
[Music]
wow look at all of that stubble but we
took care of it so let's get the Dalai
Lama in here
[Music]
all right so Mr llama thank you for uh
for coming for coming in for starters
keep the tongue in your mouth Hello
Steven I see that you had a little
trouble with your um with your stubble
there before but now it's completely
clean shaven how'd you take it off
ancient Tibetan Proverbs says
that
Assurance scrotum brings Enlightenment
yeah but I was talking about your head
yeah though I've shown that too well
good yeah there's no proverb for that no
only
manscaped oh he's got the lawnmower 4.0
it really does get the job done and by
the way it's a good time to get it with
the Hefty tax refund that's headed your
way you get 20 off free shipping with
the code Crowder 20 at manscaped.com
Texas get out of here you bald
tongue-sucking freak gosh
thank you
[Music]
hold on a second yeah do you have the uh
you have the weed whacker the the what
is this yeah I need to do you do the
nose hair I I do I never did it before
until someone said that's gross I don't
even know not jail I don't want all your
stupid Electronics that's good stuff
though that's that's fine that's why if
you I use manscape so if you were to
cover me in oil I'd slip right out of
here really that's cheating and
grappling competition by the way I know
I can't be getting you in a I can't get
you an inverted heel hook when you're
all oily I know and I wrestle with no
clothes on so but that's not because
it's an advantage if I get in a fight I
take my it's like Turkish yeah they do
that Turkish oil wrestling I know all
about it actual sport do all about it I
know it
lived it until I got myself through
college Turkish oil wrestling no it's an
actual sport like oh yes we see the
Graco Roman it's about okay we need to
add greased up nipples that's right uh
big guys big oil and mustaches that's
all I say oil and mustaches but you know
what they trim their nose hair yeah they
do I didn't realize how hairy this until
I started showing it just you know this
is so was it this is the oh it's called
the weed whacker 2.0 but the trimmer is
the 4.0 and by the way they have the
balls to sponsor the show manscapes.com
you get 20 off you know what I will say
this uh I had a really expensive like
barber shop that just hit the camera I
had a really expensive Barber Shop
trimmer like you know that you like it
and I will say it's it the battery lasts
longer because like it's big but the one
thing about the manscape the beard
trimmer now is you can you can actually
wash it under running water which is so
much more convenient and it's a lot
easier so it's got the light so that's
yeah I mean I don't know what trimmer is
better than the next one does it trim
the beard great can I rinse it off
quickly it works I don't think we're
gonna be covering any of the stories
today are we no because we do have that
exclusive call between I do but that
we'll we'll cover that next time okay we
have a lot to cover next week including
the ESG go to briancallen.com what's
your upcoming show Brian I'm going to be
at Port Charlotte uh right outside of
Fort Myers and uh great right in the
middle of my promo
unbelievable it's my comedy's too
dangerous go to rumble yes go to rumble
he's the most dangerous man in Canada's
men in comedy and then I got the stress
styles of my lungs that sounds like it's
the green fire it's the guy from Jaws oh
he's found so long it needs a last meal
oh I don't know I don't know listen
that's great we've all been traveling a
lot a lot a lot uh all right so
brian.com
Port Charlotte Florida May 5th May 6th
and you know what we are going to be
talking you know what here let's uh talk
about the zelinski and uh XI Xing ping
call we're going to continue this
because we have the exclusive audio of
the phone call uh but exclusively and by
the way if you are not a member a lot of
credit.com if you're on Rumble right now
you go right down there click that
button and you get to watch another 45
minutes to hour of show depending on how
exhausted Brian Callan is this man
doesn't sleep he lives a very full life
right now thank you Rumble YouTube you
can piss
we also have a Friday show tomorrow of
course you know Friday's show Nick the
polo show Brian count special but right
now YouTube piss off
ha
[Music]